from The Daily Mail ladies and gentlemen
Anheuser-Busch Executives hold
closed-door meeting with beer
distributors and told them any marketing
will be heavily screened before it goes
public bosses held the closed door
meeting in D.C this week where they laid
out plans going forward they say that
bench benj Steinman editor of beer
marketers Insight said the spending on
the brand fell off a cliff last year but
Anheuser Bush execs are promising to
rectify the situation Bud Light sales
have fallen dramatically since the Dylan
Mulvaney boycott which I think most of
you know now they're reporting this Bud
light's pores plummet before partnering
with Mulvaney in April 1st it dropped by
six percent to the 15th but in one
supermarket chain Bud Light sales
plunged 50 percent at Stu Leonard so the
Tri-State air this is Westchester County
Long Island Connecticut New Jersey the
reason why this story is so significant
ladies and gentlemen is because this is
a Democrat Urban liberal stronghold
seeing one of the biggest declines so
when we hear Kid Rock is you know taking
a gun and firing upon a bunch of Bud
Lights we're like oh well yeah he's Kid
Rock you know he's out in the country or
whatever he wants to be a cowboy baby or
something and you know I don't know is
that what the song was yeah okay well
there you go with the top lead back and
the Sunshine you get it you get it so
but we expect conservatives to do that
when we get news that they're having an
emergency meeting in DC and in a major
liberal area Connecticut New Jersey Long
Island that beer sales are dropping 50
percent at a major regional Supermarket
uh boycott's working yeah
congratulations everybody two honors was
known as the Disneyland of uh uh I love
students it's the best thing of all time
highly recommend going the one that was
near me uh had all of the like fruits
that sing and stuff like that like if if
you can't keep people in your store if
you can't get them to buy Bud Light
under those circumstances like you're
just not going to there's no better
grocery store being from New England you
know originally and and you know living
New Hampshire the fact that I haven't
heard this this uh change it's not what
it's not as far like Connecticut is the
only part of New England that has it
like it doesn't get to Massachusetts
you're too far gone okay uh but it is it
is delightful and I'm glad that their
customers are apparently taking part in
this boycott I never would have guessed
check this out they say uh
on top of the marketing Blitz Executives
working for Bud Light will go through a
more rigorous screening process
according to one Northeast based beer
distributor quote there will be an
improved screening process before any
marketing hits the public Executives
will have to go through a more rigorous
screening process according to beer
Business Daily wholesalers received a
letter in which Executives explained the
entire situation including quote this
was one single can given to one social
media influencer this can was not made
for production or sale to the general
public they are trying to trick people
the issue wasn't that one can was made
the issue was Dylan Mulvaney promoting
the beer in general yeah we have an
influencer among in our midst you know
influencers make money off of the post
right it's not that we have to have his
face on every single beer can it's the
fact that he is getting paid to promote
it that you guys thought this was worth
the money
a lot of money and worth access to its
audience I think that's the biggest
thing you know they're trying so hard to
act like nothing's happening but there
was that uh that video I don't know if
we should we talked about it last night
but this guy in Las Vegas he's a Las
Vegas vlogger that's what he does he's
walking into stores and being like I
wonder if this is a thing and then he's
like oh wow no one's buying Bud Light
yeah I I was I was questioning whether
or not this would have impact and when
it initially started
um I was a little apprehensive about the
idea I thought that it would look like
people were attacking Dylan and it has
turned into what looks like the most
effective uh boycott the rightest scene
in a long long time I can't remember the
last time that there's been a boycott of
of something from the right that has
been this effective well and it's
obvious that people are upset with the
brand yeah and they're really focusing
on the brand not the person which is
good because then it doesn't seem like
you're bullying right and it was kind of
they were talking about Dylan the first
two days which is reasonable because you
know sure bringing him in and all that
but it turned into the brand which I
think is that's the correct approach
because they're the ones that made the
decision they're the ones that make the
product they're the people that people
want to buy the product from is it every
now the the actual cans or bottles in
the stores it was like a limited run
that actually had Dylan's face on them
no they only from what I remember in
Phil can correct me here they only made
this one can to celebrate 365 days of
girl to Mark the one year point of
Dylan's hole where those in stores
they just made a custom thing
gotcha but that wasn't the issue right
because the video I saw first was Dylan
with a bunch of beers saying I don't
even know what March Madness is let's
all drink beer and then cracking open
beer had nothing to do with any kind of
promotional can or anything like that
and then all of a sudden everyone was
like screw Bud Light and it's tagged
with the like hashtag Bud Light spot a
partner or something like that like it's
denoted as a form of advertising I think
what the strangest part of it like like
you're right I'm actually glad that
there's not a specific targeting filming
because Domo vanity is doing exactly
what Dylan Mulvaney has always done and
you can have separate criticism of that
but Anheuser-Busch chose to partner with
him and if yeah you put position people
in positions of power in your company
who thought this was a good idea I'm
glad that you're starting to rethink
this I would like them to admit that
they're just saying like our rigorous
screening processes we will hire some
conservatives after years and years of
hiring liberals probably what they're
talking about is okay we can't say we
goofed up and they're all fired because
then the trans Community will say we're
horrible and bigoted and all of that and
so I mean not even though here's how I
imagine the meeting goes down they tell
everybody look we understand you're
concerned we're gonna have a meeting in
DC come meet and they all walk in
there's a guy in his suit and he goes
listen our customers are dumb as dumb
guests they are so stupid so here's what
we're gonna do We're Not Gonna apologize
We're not gonna say anything we're gonna
completely ignore all of them and let it
all blow over that's that's what they're
saying right now I mean I I don't know
if it's quite that extreme but they are
definitely trying to be like they're
definitely trying to run away from it as
opposed to addressing it and saying
they're sorry and I do think that that
apologizing uh is appropriate because
they it's they're they're they're seeing
a a distinct reaction from their their
user base from their their customer base
that's what brands are built on many
many of you may be wondering why why is
this so important why have we talked
about this for three weeks now why are
we leading the show with it right now
because I want to make sure that every
major corporation knows that when you
engage in sponsorships and advertisings
advertising like this it will be so
toxic to your company you will be
reeling from it there has been no resp
it's been it's been entirely uh no
negative response from all of the
essentially since you know the the since
June became you know pride month and has
been celebrated so openly in the west
and and for probably the past 10 years
or so there's not been any kind of
considerable pushback and to see
something you know pushing back to say
hey maybe we should moderate this a
little bit because at this point the
trans question like that that is not
that is not built on on solid arguments
there's there's a lot of questions there
are people that there's there's evidence
that that it's not a good idea to
yeah exactly like they like multiple
countries in Europe have said no it's
not working yeah and then you there's
even been several studies showing that
could it could increase suicidal
ideation so let's make sure we're
helping people 100 but but more more to
the point my biggest concern is
they effectively sponsored Elsa gate
right the easiest way for me to explain
what went down with the Dilma Benny
sponsorship is a person exploited an
algorithm for to produce strange and
off-putting content that was offensive
to a lot of women a lot of uh and I'll
end men and then Budweiser did no
research said whatever look this
person's got followers it must be
popular but I do think it's a fantastic
wake-up call as to what AI is doing to
humans humans and what AI promotes or I
shouldn't say AI but algorithms sure it
is incongruous just because someone has
views does not mean they are popular and
this proves it and I hope that if we
keep the pressure on
than other corporations will start to
realize like hey look just because that
person's on TV doesn't mean they're
popular you're gonna get the algorithms
to really internalize retweets or not
endorsements that's right we get that
idea to go to really I used to see sorry
I was gonna say I've heard some
YouTubers say like yeah I don't care if
you dislike my video any interaction
actually helps I don't know if that's
still the case I'm not that experienced
with YouTube but it is yeah so so really
like anyone commenting on Dylan's posts
this is terrible is actually just still
helping yeah you do you get into the
comments on on T-Rex arm stuff still
currently all right as as much as I can
and primarily to learn more about our
customers not any other reason
um we talked to some marketing folks
last week who said yeah even if your
company responds to every comment on you
know Instagram YouTube Facebook uh that
greatly affects the algorithm even if
you stop by and go thumbs up you're
adding to the comment count and that
makes a difference so when do you get
the trans Shooters well
um yeah wait a minute
oh my God I have no idea what you're
talking about I apologize
posted a photo a year ago and it was uh
it was a gun on a trans flag and I said
something like trans rights are human
rights trans gun rights are human rights
and I got a false DM my I believe it was
a false dmca takedown activists started
this is the weirdest thing leftist
screen grabbed my post and then started
insulting me over it and I'm like it's
it's so weird that I said something they
should agree with and instead they
attacked me and then filed the dmca
takedown to get the video the photo
deleted from my Twitter account and then
I'm just like I don't know what these
people think because I'm like two-way
all the way I had a guy tweeted me
saying you you think only white people
should have guns I'm like what are you
talking about I think the Black Panther
should be marching around with guns all
day every day and they're like oh okay
bass yeah
where these people live in a wacky
alternate dimension of what we here
believe it it is interesting though I
did notice and I I could be wrong an
uptick in the obviously when the
shooting occurred a couple weeks ago
there were lots of Gun Company these and
I also tweeted some things about
um you know calling into question you
know should gun companies and this is a
big discussion happening right now do we
have to serve and service everyone who
wants to own a gun or can we go hey this
is what we believe is a company we're
interested in selling to these types of
people
um absolutely we put our core values out
there and usually some people aren't
going to agree with those so they're not
going to come and buy from us and it did
look like after the the shooting in in
um in Tennessee occurred uh the trans
Community was definitely much more
interested in talking about guns and gun
rights for themselves and getting
involved in that whole things I had all
kinds of people to stopping by my
Twitter giving their opinion and I feel
like a year ago probably when you posted
that flag that was not as much of a
discussion and they're probably more
anti-gun no they're like oh no now we
need to be pro-gun they were pro-gun
yeah there was there was a it was a
picture of a trans flag with a gun on it
and then there was people were posting
pictures of trans people wearing patches
and armbands of the trans flag with guns
and I'm like I'm all for it thanks for
watching this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time